partygate is no longer secure ground for
kiestama's questions after allegations
about his own pandemic conduct so the
labour leader ditched that favorite
topic for this one
when will he stop the hokey cokey and
just back labour's plan for a windfall
tax to cut household bills still
pretending the economy is booming still
got his head in the sand in the middle
of an economic crisis
and secure didn't just attack the pm but
the man sitting next to him too rishi
sunak is under pressure to act but it
was striking how little he prompted the
pm today and his subdued demeanor was
reflected across the chamber it is
rarely quite so quiet
if you speak to team stammer they are
convinced a u-turn is coming on a
windfall tax on oil and gas profits one
senior figure told me it will happen
unless the government are quotes
literally mad and if and when it does
labour want to make sure voters remember
it's been their policy their position
for months now the pm blamed global
factors and he did seem skeptical of a
windfall tax but he did not rule it out
we will look at all the measures that we
need to take uh mr speaker to get people
through to the other side mr johnson
also went on the attack on tax
the labor's plans are always and
everywhere to raise taxes on business
his answer in addition to putting up
taxes his answer is to borrow him on
their lust to raise taxes on business
mrs b
we don't
we don't relish it
we don't want to do it even though of
course his government has raised taxes
to their highest level since world war
ii sky news analysis of the labour
leaders language today shows his key
theme people who can't pay their bills
the word chancellor also appears a lot
investment and the economy feature in
boris johnson's responses
elsewhere kiestama criticized jacob
rees-mogg's crusade against civil
servants working from home the member
for north east somerset
when he's not when he's not sticking
notes on people's desks like some
overgrown prefect
provoking a grin from the minister
when is he finally gonna the lib dems
focused on farming from caithness to
cumbria from shropshire to devon
farmers own input costs are spiraling
upwards far from a coincidence with a
by-election in rural devon coming up
and one tory mp managed to slip in a dig
about the kiestarma beergate rao
so it's more than just a place to bring
friends for a social evening of beer and
takeaway curry and an even better place
to live work than bring up a family
we now seem to have reached a tipping
point on the cost of living crisis with
a situation quite so stark the longer it
takes the government to act the bigger
the advantage for labour solutions will
of course be expensive but we do expect
the chancellor to announce something
within weeks